for months during the rainy season large
parts of Bangladesh are regularly under
water the large rivers overflow and
flood huge areas often ferocious
cyclones destroyed people's homes and
farmland their livelihoods and their
lives at times like this the longed-for
rain becomes a curse a trip along the
Brahmaputra River shows the extent of
the erosion the floodwaters eat into the
land parts of the bank break off
disappearing into the river but the
country's population of 160 million need
every bit of arable land ko Kamiya who
is over 70 years old has seen many
floods in his lifetime once he was a
wealthy farmer with his own rice fields
he has 6 sons and several grandchildren
but repeated flooding made it harder and
harder to feed his family 11 times the
floods have taken everything away my
fields my house 11 times we had to move
and start over again then came the next
flood and destroyed everything over and
over again 11 times two years ago we
ended up here the floods have turned us
into refugees the landless farmers have
found ways of cultivating these sandy
sediments along the river they dig pits
fertilize them with cow manure and plant
pumpkins
since the thick shelled squash keep for
a long time they can be sold at a profit
during the barren winter months simple
but clever strategies like these are
needed if Bangladesh is to meet the
challenges of climate change near mile
Chandra BAP re is agriculture manager
for the Bangladesh branch of the charity
practical action he's convinced that
planting suitable crops in the sandbars
will help the most impoverished
Bangladeshis cope with climate change
then I think it will be Menace then when
the first storms announced the start of
the monsoon period people will be able
to look to the future with more optimism